that's right the Super Bowl just
happened the Ravens fought the 49ers
then a power outage happened then about
9 million Bane jokes hit Twitter all at
once so then the 49ers were the comeback
Kings but then they ended up losing
anyway but don't worry we got some movie
trailers so even if you're a 49ers fan
it's still a win for you movie trailers
are always cool and yeah I'm gonna do
one on star trek into darkness also but
I'm gonna do one on Iron Man 3 first the
funny thing about the Iron Man 3 trailer
during the Super Bowl is it wasn't
really a trailer as much as it was a
scene like one of those oh hey sneak
peek by the way Air Force one gets a
rocket smacked into it people get blown
out of the plane and now Iron Man needs
to save the day we saw a glimpse of that
in the trailer before but this is where
the potentially cool part comes in how
many in the air Jarvis
alright 13 people are falling to their
deaths is Air Force one so the probably
important people as far as government
goes so important but the next question
comes and this is the important part
and that's what could be really cool
that I don't think is gonna be as cool
as I want it to be but it's just that's
why I got to talk about this 13 people
are falling to their deaths Iron Man can
carry for the way he just so
nonchalantly says oh boy so like another
day at the office let's go to work you
feel like it's like Oh spoiler alert I'm
gonna save everybody
it's probably gonna be the case I'm
pretty sure all 13 people are gonna be
fine alive and well I don't want that to
happen I think that would be really cool
if Iron Man 3 just goes the extra step
and it's like up 13 people falling to
their death you can say four choose this
is Fire Emblem and you gotta choose
who lives and dies that to me would take
Iron Man 3 from awesome comic book movie
into holy
this is really monumental you imagine
that nine people die because iron man
was just powerless to save them then he
goes home and sucks the videos like dude
I suck at my job my job is just being
awesome and I suck at it now I would
love to live in a world where Iron Man 3
makes the tough kind of calls it like
Breaking Bad makes I don't like
comparing everything to Breaking Bad but
9 out of 10 things in the dramatic world
of entertainment can probably link back
to Breaking Bad or at least be compared
to it Breaking Bad is one of those shows
like now bad things happen and people
die because of it I would love to see
Iron Man 3 do that that's why I had to
talk about this first I don't think
it'll go down that way I'm pretty sure
Tony Stark's gonna somehow save
everybody or Rody's gonna fly in and
save everybody also but in a more
why I'm just telling you straight out I
would love to see nine people die in
that same
and that's really all there was for
Ironman 3 in the Super Bowl so now I got
to ask you guys what do you think should
happen in this scene what do you think's
gonna happen in this scene comment below
let me know you know you want him to die
and as always if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more